Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Doki Doki literature club. Now,
We got to figure out who we're gonna show our poem to first!
I don't remember who we showed it to first last time, but I guess it doesn't matter
Let's go to Monika at least Hey Monika! Hi morp, How's it going?
Have you thought about what you want to submit to perform at the festival?
Well, being in this club is one thing but performing in front of a bunch of people
I'll have to give it some more thought. Okay. No pressure, but whatever you do,
I'm sure it'll turn out great. It would also make me happy to see hahahaha
Okay, anyway, let's take a look at today's poem, sure. I let MoniKa take the poem I'm holding in my hands. All right
I like this one
It makes me think of something Sayori would like. Is that so? You and say are your really good friends, right?
I wouldn't be surprised if you had those sort of things in common. Oh well
We may be good friends, but say Sayori and I are actually really different. Hmmm?
Well that may be the case, but maybe there's also some similarities that you wouldn't expect the way she talks about you
It sounds like the two of you really care about each other's well-being
Even if you show it in different ways it ends up being more similar than you think
So I think that's the kind of vibe I get when I read your poem
Hmm, I didn't write that you sure you're not reading into it too much Monika
Haha, could be yeah, could be oh gosh, I sound like Yuri, but any case Sayori's writing is that kind of gentle feel to it
I can tell you she likes exploring with emotions like happiness and sadness who knew that someone so happy would enjoy sad things, too.
Yeah, it's totally unexpected well, to each their own, and you shouldn't be afraid to experiment a little bit either anyway
I'll share my poem with you now all right?
all right.
I wonder how this is gonna go?
"The Lady Who Knows Everything", an old tale tells of a lady who wanders earth the lady who knows everything a
beautiful lady who's found every answer: all meaning, all purpose, and all that was ever sought, and here I am a
Feather- where's my mouse- a feather lost a drift the sky victim of the currents of the wind day after day
I searched. I search with little hope knowing legends don't exist but when all else has failed me when all others have turned away
The ledgend is all that remains the last dim star glimmering in the twilight sky
The twil-lit sky, until one day the wind ceases to blow I fall and I fall and fall and fall even more
Gentle as a feather, a dry quill expressionless
But a hand catches me between the thumb and forefinger the hand of a beautiful lady
I look at her eyes and find no end to her gaze
The lady who knows everything knows what I'm thinking. Before I can speak she responds in a hollow voice
I have found every answer all of which amount to nothing. There is no meaning
There is no purpose
And we seek only the impossible I am NOT your legend, your legend does not exist. And with a breath
She blows me back afloat, and I pick up a gust of wind. (end poem)
Okay
all right, you know,
I feel like learning and looking for answers are the sort of things that give life meaning.
Not to get too philosophical or anything, but it was kinda on my mind, so that's what I wrote about. I see.
Okey-dokey, then. I never really put my thought into it.
In a way, it's almost paradoxical because even if we had all the answers wouldn't the world start to lose its meaning?
You know, there's one thing I noticed, seems like everyone in the club prefers writing about things that are more sad than happy
Haha, are you surprised? I mean, if everything was okay,
We wouldn't really have anything to write about would we? Humans aren't two-dimensional creatures,
I think you'd know that better than anyone. You mean one dimensional?
Ah, yeah, that, anyway. Here's Monica's writing tip of the day. Are you ever too? Shy to share your writing because you're afraid
It's not that good?
It can be really disheartening to get a lukewarm response to something you put so much into
But if you find other people who enjoy writing then sharing becomes a lot easier, because instead of just telling you that your writing is
Good, or okay, or bad
They'll want to focus more on everything that went into it and the things you can work on
It's much more encouraging that way, and it'll make you want to continue improving. It's almost like having your own little Literature Club,
don't you think? That's my advice for you today! Okay, and, uh
Considering that my response to your poem may have been a little lukewarm
Are you gonna, you gonna do something about that, you're gonna hold that against me, are you gonna be very angry at me? I don't know.
Thanks for listening. Okay. All right. Who should I show my poem to next? Well
Let's go straight to Sayori this time. Hey Sayori. How you doing? Hmm? It's nice, I guess.
Come on. I can already tell you don't like it--
*Mark's Siri picks up something and interrupts him. The music stops while Siri talks*
Thank you? Haha
Siri just picked up on something I said
Lets see. You don't need to worry about what I think. After all, you wrote this for someone else, didn't you? Probably Yuri...
Ehhh? I didn't write this for anyone specifically!
Maybe, that's not really what I meant though. It's okay, you're making new friends,
Just like I was hoping that makes me really happy and you're happy too, right?
In this club?
Well, of course I am! Good, that's all that matters to me.
I feel like there should be something else that matters to you Sayori, considering, I picked this poem to be for you.
Sayori, is there something wrong? Ah,
No, nothing. I'm just a little tired today
Hehehehe
Alright, just tell me if you need anything. I will don't worry about me, okay
You can go play with everyone else now. If you insist, I'll go play... yeah that's what we're doing...
I'm gonna go home a little bit early today. Sayori... Tell Monica I wasn't feeling well, kay? I'll see you tomorrow
Before I can say anything else Sayori cheerfully walks out of the classroom humming to herself
That's-that's a little weird
huh
peculiar... Natsuki?
Hello! This one's alright. Alright?! No one likes my poem!
Yeah, it doesn't blow me away, but there's nothing really I hate about it. It's just not really my style
I mean that's fine come to think of it this reminds me of Sayori's poem from yesterday
Yeah, you think so. Yeah. Well. I guess have you been friends with her for so long you might be on the same wavelength
But you never really struck me as her type Sayori has a type all of the sudden??
Oh, I don't know, but honestly how can someone so?... Eh
Fluffy spend so much time with someone like you? It's like she's dragging around a dead weight. Well, uh,
Thank you for that. Well. It was a little unnecessary, but I think of it this way if it weren't for me,
She probably would just fly away like letting go a balloon.
You could say we each take care of each other in our own way
Whatever it is. I don't get it. Oh yeah. I guess I'm supposed to show you my poem here. Yeah sure okay
Thanks for the insult
I'll be your Beach your mind is so full of troubles and fears that diminished your wonder over the years, but today
I have a special place a beach for us to go ashore reaching beyond your sight a sea that sparkles with brilliant light
The walls in your mind will melt away before the sunny glow. I'll be the beach that washes your worries away
I'll be the beach that you daydream about each day
Oh, I'll be the Beach that makes your heart leap in a way you thought had left you long ago
Let's bury your heavy thoughts in a pile of sand
Bathed in sunbeams and hold my hand wash your insecurities in the salty sea and let me see you shine
Let's leave your memories in a footprint trail
Set you free and my windy sail and remember the reasons you're wonderful when you press your lips to mine oh
I'll be the beach that washes your worries away. I'll be the beach that you daydream about each day
I'll be the beach that makes your heart leap in a way you thought
You'd left long ago
But if you let me by your side your own beach your own escape you're learning to love yourself again. This is beautiful!
Yeah, I felt like I kept writing about negative things so I wanted to write something with a nice message for once, besides the beach
Is awesome kind of hard to write anything negative about the beach
So you decided to write about the beach first and then came up with the message later? Yeah well
It's only because of what happened yesterday
I mean after Yuri and I realized we kind of wrote about the same thing
She wanted to pick a topic and have us both write about it or whatever. Oh, you really can see her doing that huh?
Making us write about a simple topic than trying to impress me by coming up with something all fancy well
It's not like I care. I just did it anyway
I mean, I guess mine ended up being kind of metaphorical, too
But there's nothing wrong with doing that once in a while at the very least it was good practice! Natsuki,
I don't have a goddamn idea what you're yammering on about!
I mean if you have something that you got a problem with just come out and say it
Alright fine, then bye all right. Yuri~
Hello, how are you? Well done Morp... ooph
No. You've defiantly improved your writing over the course of these few days.
Thanks picked of random words out of a hat sure, worked out well for me. Has my advice been helpful to you? Nahh.... yeah, defiantly.
I'm glad sharing our writing like this. It's a lot more fun and rewarding than I anticipated
I'll need to remember to thank Monika.
I think we all felt a little awkward at first
But now it seems like everyone is enjoying sharing their writing and seeing what others think I guess I can't really disagree
I was afraid this whole thing would be a chore
But it's a great way for me to spend some personal time with all the girls in the club
But it's been fun to get to know everyone in their writing.
But I guess doing some writing myself if you call throwing darts at words on a wall writing, but that's just my creative process, baby.
Well have you learned anything about yourself Morp nope not a thing. I'm a blank slate. I'm totally empty inside
Well, you know how I'd like to say that writing is a very personal way to get in touch with yourself
I don't remember you ever saying that in the end it doesn't matter if you're a good writer
Or a bad writer, and even my opinions are just my opinions, ya know?
As always I believe what's most important is exploring and discovering yourself
That's comforting because I have a funny feeling your
Your desires are a little off-putting. I'm kind of afraid of disappointing you in some other way... Eh?
Why me well you're always sophisticated with your writing and have the most advice to share.
Is that so? I'm so... embarrassed!
Yuri thinks for a good minute. That must be terrible.
Eh? For me to have become someone whose opinion is fearsome. How unlikable of me
Yuri~ it's not as bad as you're making out sound in your head. I mean. It's really bad, but not that bad
I just mean that I respect your opinion. I see.
I'm sorry that I always overthink and come to those sorts of conclusions. I'm just a little too used to it
Overthinking it being disliked.
Oh, Yuri.
What what am I saying? I'm sorry. I didn't mean to bring that up god. It's so hard being a tall beautiful anime girl. Oh
God why why have I been cursed with these qualities. Let's move on all right?
Do you want to share your poem now okay here?
Here we are
Beach a
Marvel millions of years in the making with a womb of Earth
chaotically meets this epic under a clear blue sky an expanse of bliss
But beneath Gray rolling clouds an endless enigma the easiest world to get lost in is one where everything
Can be found one can only build a sandcastle where the sand is wet but where the sand is wet the tide comes
Will it gently lick at your foundations until you give in?
Woah, woah, w-o-o-ahh, oh!
Will its sudden wave send you
crashing down in the blink of an eye either way the outcome is the same yet still we build sandcastles I
Stand where the foam wraps around my ankles where my toes squish in the sand, the salty air is
Therapeutic the breeze is gentle yet powerful
I sink my toes into the ultimate boundary line tempted by the foamy tendrils.
Turn back and I abandon my piece to erode at the shore. Drift forward
And I've returned to the earth
forevermore ah
Beautiful beautiful um I'm aware that the beach is kind of an inane thing to write about
The beach what's wrong with the beach you got a problem with the beach lady?
I got a problem with you if you've got a problem with the beach.
Although the beach is close to the ocean therefore, I now suddenly have a problem with the beach and I want it to die.
But I did my best to make a metaphorical approach to it. Yeah, Natsuki already told me about it
She she did? she didn't say anything weird did she she just want us to write about the same topic again?
I supposed to better compare the differences in our writing styles our thought processes. Yeah, probably anyway. It was her idea not mine
Knowing her it's no surprise that she'd want to do something like that she probably just wants to show off
It's not like I have a particular interest in a writing style. It's just I went with her a request like a friend would.
But well I suppose it's not so bad or write about something simple on occasion it can be refreshing
You know it's good for me to calm my thoughts once in a while. Yeah, I think I agree
Even though it's kind of crazy, and you're kind of worried about what everyone thinks about you too much. Thanks for sharing all right
Hi, Monika. Okay, you three. We're all done sharing poems, right?
Why don't you start figuring out-hold on a second! Is it just me, or did you say something strange just now?
Eh? Something did sound a bit unusual... that's right, you deviated from your usual catchphrase when addressing the club
Catchphrase, I don't have a catchphrase
Geez why is the mood so weird today look even Yuri isn't immune to it
Stagnating air is common for shadow and that's something terrible is
Hey, woah woah woah, hey wait a minute.
What's happening? In your books maybe, look the only things different is that Sayori isn't here? Ah...
It seems you're right
sigh
Sayori always helps lighten the mood a little bit doesn't she it's almost like everyone's bounce is thrown off a little when she's not around
What the heck did you run off to anyway? I thought she just went to pee
Natsuki, please show some decency Well come on everybody pees
She actually wasn't feeling too well went home early Is that so? I hope she's all right... Seriously?
All the times to not go home with her you picked the time She's not feeling well so much for you to being old
No first of all stop misunderstanding my friendship and only friendship just friends with Sayori
Second we're just friends. She's kind of been avoiding me today, so I didn't want to force it
That curious expression coming from Yuri of all people Calm down guys. I talked to her earlier and everything is fine
What did she say? Anyway, we need--
Anyway, forget what you said Morp, you don't matter. I'm
manipulating things behind the scenes apparently, anyway, we need to figure out the rest of the festival preparations so
Let's decide what everyone will be doing this weekend. I already know what I'm doing
What are you doing? That's right,
Natsuki will be  aking cupcakes. Ah okay, but we need a lot of them in different flavors
Can you handle all those by yourself Natsuki?
challenge accepted
and so for myself
I'm gonna be printing and assembling all the poetry pamphlets Sayori will be helping me design them, as for Yur- As for Yuri
Yuri you can...
Ehhh guys, can you help me come up with something for Yuri?
I.... am useless ahhh
I'm use-.... oh shittt
Didn't mean for that to come true. Okay. No that's not it at all. You're the most talented person here. You know
Bitch now now Natsui's pouting now too, jeez even I can tell now I guess I never gave Sayori enough cerdit
But I can tell things are even harder when on you when she's not around ah
That may be the case, but if I can't also be a leader on my own
Then I won't grow as a person, so Yuri, you have beautiful handwriting
You know so you should make some banners and decorations to help set the atmosphere
atmosphere I'm about that I I
love
atmosphere
Yuri's expression suddenly changes as if she's stares at the desk in focus and starts nodding to herself. Your mind is already racing I see.
That's great. You'll be a wonderful help Yuir, but anyway, that just leaves you Morp
Yeah, the one who is truly useless I accept my useless nature
I will go on my way and do absolutely nothing because anything that I would do would be a detriment to your wonderful Club
Haha, don't say that in fact both Natsuki and Yuri have some pretty heavy tasks to handle
It would probably go a long way to give one of them a hand you could always help me out as well
it would really appreciative of that ah
That's is Monika suggesting I spent the weekend with one of my club members
Yeah, how on earth are they gonna respond to his suggestion like that? Oh, I suppose. I wouldn't mind a bit of help oh
We-eh-eh-eh-eh-ellll Welll, eh ehe, we-e-ell.
Don't mind if I do
Yeah, well even if you don't know how to bake. There's always some dirty work
I could give you it's not like Monika's going to give me a choice
And you shouldn't be sitting on your butt anyway Natsuki tries to mumble a bunch of excuses like that um
If I recall Natsuki you mentioned that you would like to handle the baking on your own
Morp may not like to be around if you only make him out to be a nuisance
So therefore he may be more suited to assisting with the decorations by my side where our thumbs can be so close
Hold on. I never said that. How hard could it be to make a few decorations anyway?
She's stupid idiot sounds more like it's just making an excuse if for Morp to- what are you saying?
It would be extremely meticulous work and baking isn't just what do you think guys guys guys?
Shut the F up, please alright God. Let's settle down for a moment, in the end
I think it's up to morp to decide how he'd like to contribute besides
He hasn't really gotten
much time to spend with me
Oh-h eh-h
Like the way you lean, I like the way you lean Monika. I like the way you lean
Alright anyway, so I'm sure he's interested in you literally just said I'm surprised as well. Sorry sorry
I was just saying though jeez can we just settle this already yeah Morp. You're okay with this, right? Oh?
Ladies ladies
There, there's Morp enough for everybody just everyone calm down here a little bit Morp know how to treat three
Ladies yeah in the end. It's up to you. Ah of course
Humph
Very well in that case
Everyone looks straight at me
See, but of course. I'm gonna go with... um, there's Sayori
ooh, the are they... *Que Mark making noises that are very hard to turn to words*
*Very monkey like* OOhhh
Ooohdie-woodie-woo
Ohh woo woo woo woo woo
Ahhh, laaaa
Okay, so here's my logic right Natsuki
Yuri and Monika are all taking care of something here or other Sayori something's obviously bothering Sayori
but also this is the first time I've been able to spend any sort of free time with Monika and
There's something about Monika the way her green eyes are creeping over that... that name bar
That just you know
Sets my heart a-fluttering
You know how it be you guys know how it is right you guys understand what I'm talking about right?
Right you don't okay. All right. Then well if you do understand what I'm talking about you know
All right, hey, I saved I'm gonna go with Monika. I know Sayori's probably needs me by her side right now, but
What?
Whatever Monika well, I guess I should probably be helping Monika
Yayy, you picked me
Hold on one second yeah
Monika you're the one who needs the least help out of all of us
But I agree with Natsuki. Not only is your work already most suitable for one person, but you already have Sayori as well
but Morp was the one who... ah
It doesn't matter, Morp
It doesn't matter you were the one who scared him into picking you in the first place the club president
Monika whose was a responsible decision for the club
Monika you shouldn't let any ulterior motives interfere with his decision ulterior motives!!??
What are you saying Yuri? in fact it sounded like you guys are the one who with ulterior
*Mark struggles to say ulterior* Al un to uh you motives
Ich eh ha ha excuse me
Otherwise this wouldn't have been made into such a big deal in the first place. That's completely false Monika
Yeah, we have a lot of work to do
You know we won't do as good a job if you make us work alone. Ah maybe
that's true think of the club Monika if we want our event to succeed that we need to appropriately distribute our resources ah
So are you gonna do the right thing president? Okay? Okay?
I get it huh it's technically most logical form Morp to help one of you two
So I guess that's what we'll do what that's bullshit, then okay
Load of garbage what what a load of big flip-flapping garbage?
I'm gonna go with Sayori then you stupid idiots I mean
If it's gonna be anyone, then I'd prefer helping Sayori
I mean we're already neighbors and but Monika said, Monki said Sayori was helping her!
Geez do you really hate us that much yep. Yep. Yes, I do yeah, sorry
I didn't mean for this to be difficult yeah, Monika. Oh sure you didn't oh, yeah, okay?
Just think of the club, okay
That's bullshit, it's bullshit. It's bullshit. You're bullshit. Oh, this is bullshit bullshit bullshit bullshit bullshit
Ugh
Bullshit, it's bullshit. Well. I'm gonna go back. Go back i'ma see both of these moot choices now
let's see if I just want to see if they're moot choices like if I pick Sayoti here I
Mean if it's gonna be Sayori. We're already neighbors, but Monica said
Wait what oh?
It's the same thing
God dammit well alright, then ugh God why do I have to pick one of you assholes that I don't care about
Uhh Natsuki, ohh Yuri Natsuki-Yuri alright. You know what you screw you guys I'm gonna flip a coin because I
Don't have one preference either way which way for one of you two. I don't care. Where's a goddamn coin
Give me a coin. Give me a coin
I don't have a coin...
I got...
Alright, I got this... I got this special, well hey
Murch, bug, I've got this special Christmas edition dog toy for chica. It's got chicas face on it if it lands face up
I'm gonna go Natsuki if it lands face down. I'm going with Ma- Yuri, here we go
Hey, it's Natsuki
Haha
All right there we are
It's just random chance cuz I just don't care can't be bothered this is bullshit, bullshit. Natsuki
Well baking sounds like it could be fun and you guys made it sound like a lot of work
So it probably could use two people don't worry baking is a ton of fun. You'll definitely agree
Ehhhh?
Just a minute ago you were saying that do that's because I didn't have a chance to go on a date with Morp!
Never mind, okay. Well anyway. You'll be fine by yourself right Yuri of
Course all alone with my poems and books. I'm used to it after all being abandoned
What a stick-in-the-mud, that's good even though. Yuir's being melodramatic. It's a little hardened to not feel bad. So that's everything right
Anything else we need to talk about no. I think that's it are you guys excited nope no
I'm not I am NOT. I am NOT. This is not what I wanted everything except the performance is gonna be awesome very cool
I don't think really I don't really think that counts what about you Morp. Me?
I guess you could say I'm interested to see how it'll turn out that's good enough for me. What about you Yuri? Yuri?
She's still sulking she's dead inside
Just like everybody else is gonna be dead on the outside
Alright, Natsuki starts pouting - it's not I mean it's not that big a deal or anything
Well it might not be just that I think the Yuri might just be feeling a little unappreciated in general
Having to come up with something for her to do and then nobody offering to help that doesn't mean
Natsuki glances back and forth between everyone with a worried expression
Look Natsuki goes over and puts her hand down on Yuri shoulders Yuri
You really are the most talented one here
And and you're gonna help make the event a lot more fun and welcoming
I mean the cupcakes will probably help a lot too, but you're gonna make the atmosphere
Special that'll be really important for the way that people feel during the performances so you need to stop being dumb
You need to stop being a stupid idiot a big dumb goofy
Ugly idiot give yourself a little more credit Natsuki releases her hands and turns around to face the other direction
You didn't really mean that did you all the screaming about how dumb I was
You didn't mean that. Did you cuz that hurt my feelings?
Umm
Not really, but Yuri isn't the only one surprised, Monika
And I are also taken aback by Natsuki's words Natsuki of all people to be saying such encouraging things
But I begin to understand and fall in love Natsuki was trying to sound like Sayori
Even if it didn't work perfectly I tell this you tried to say something Sayori
Would say at a time like this because Sayori always helps everyone smile and feel good about themselves.
I'm sorry for... being a... Big. Dumb.
Stinky stupid idiot I'm gonna do my bestest and all of us are gonna make a really great event yeah
Yeahh!
I hope to see everyone do their best
But with that that's the thing more for today, so I guess it's our time for head to head out, okay?
But I'm staying here a bit longer that barely got to do any reading today, so fair enough. There's nothing wrong with that
Everyone bags up their things. I started to follow Monica and Yuri out the door as they chat between each other um
Where are you going?
Ehh?
We still need to figure out our plans for this weekend
You literally would have gotten home and realized that you didn't even have a way to contact me. Oh that's true right okay?
I have no idea how that slipped my mind, maybe because I just didn't care jeez good thing
I stopped you you big dumb idiot. I'm giving you my number. Okay. Don't really -
It's amazing I'll be able to predict the following dialogue. Why would I do that?
Natsuki gives me her number. Okay. I'm coming over on Sunday. I'll bring all the ingredients
Wait you're coming to my house
Yeah, what's wrong with that? I mean. I just figured that since I'm the one helping I would go into your house
Yeah, right
creepy weirdo
Like I could have a guy over at my house, my dad would kill me!
Really, it's kind of strict. If you ask me. Yeah. How do you think I feel? I could do anything with my dad home anyway
I just need to complain for a second we have each other's numbers now
That's all I needed from you and nothing else. So you go eff off
See you on Sunday, okay, so I'll text you when I'm coming over. Fine by me, yeah, I'm really gonna
Show you why I love oh
Well, I'm gonna show you why I love bacon so let's go
Oh, I'm gonna. Show you what you're gonna see oh you're gonna see so you better look forward to it oh yeah
Didn't you say you were just gonna give me the dirty work? Oh?
Give me the dirty work all right
Well, I was just saying that no like I could act like
In front of everyone that's that I was looking forward to this wait really
Well kind of just because I never got to bake with someone else before that's always who
Right I get it, sorry for overacting anyway. I'll be heading home now, see you on Sunday
Never mind
All Right see ya, okay
I can't believe this
Natsuki is gonna be coming to my house on Sunday even though I would have preferred to do this with Sayori
My anxiety still shoots through the roof
I guess I've gotten pretty used to handling her at this point
But who knows what might end up happening when we're outside of school
She even told me she was looking forward to it. Maybe we're going to
Kiss in whatever I shake my head. Oh god. I shouldn't think such naughty thoughts
Why do I feel nervous if Sayori finds out about this?
It's not like we feel THAT way about each other besides like Monika said this is about the club
I have nothing to worry about if I just go with it then I'll have a good time
If I just go with it, okay?
It's already Sunday wow that was fast. Okay wait hang on go save it's already Sunday
I've been getting increasingly anxious about Natsuki's
upcoming visit. I keep telling myself
There's no reason to be nervous, but it doesn't help much, I wonder
If she'll act any different when it's just the two of us. Oh geez meanwhile
She's been texting me a lot. We sent each other one after exchanging numbers to double-check, but it turned into a conversation
She's almost a different personality on the phone using tons of emoji and cute language
She also really likes complaining about things, but I saw that one coming
putting Natsuki aside
I haven't heard a thing from Sayori since she left club early that other day
It's not like we text each other all of the time or anything
But I've been worried about her in the back of my mind
Between what Sayori said and what Monika said, iseally okay for me to put Sayori
feelings aside when she might need me
Probably not I decided to visit Sayori right before Natsuki comes over rather than asking
I simply tell her I'm coming over much like we've done in the past once. I reach Sayori's house
I knock on the door before entering it myself again
We used to play-I got a bad feeling about this place-often though
We made it a habit of simply entering each other's houses like we're family-got a bad feeling about this-the house is quiet
Sayori isn't anywhere on the first floor, so I assume she's up in her room
It's already strange of her not to run down and greet me head up to her bedroom where I finally find her
Sayori. Oh.
Hi Morp. I sit down in her room.
Sayori forces a smile
But it's easy to tell that she's different
There's a minute of silence between us you haven't come over like this in a long time
Have you ah I guess you're right.It's been a long time not much has really changed has it
Sayori's room is as messy as it's always been I also recognize the same stuffed animals in wall decorations that she's had for years now
Heh, if you came over more often? It wouldn't be such a mess that's because I end up cleaning it up for you
How come you suddenly wanted to come over today? Aren't you supposed to see Natsuki today?
Yeah
But wait how did you know that Sayori had already left by the time we decided that last meeting
Monika told me, it's only natural for her to keep me informed about the festival preparations. Right? Ah, that's true.
maybe
But what about you aren't you going to be helping Monika today of course, but I'm just helping her online
We didn't plan to meet up or anything ah so, it's just me and Natsuki then
right
Yeparooni, more silence between us series stares in a random direction everything about it behavior is really uncharacteristic
I'm finally getting the point
I just wanted to see how her you were doing after you left on Friday when something's wrong. You can't hide it from me
I know you too well
Soo
Sayori smiles, shaking her head, that's no good Morp.
Why can't it just be like it's always been this is all my fault
If I didn't get so weak and accidentally express my feelings if I didn't make that
Stupid mistake, then you wouldn't have been worried about me at all you wouldn't have come here
You wouldn't have haven't even been thinking about me right now, but this is this my punishment isn't it?
I'm getting punished for being so selfish. I think that's why the world decided to have you come over today
It just wants to torture me he-he. Okay... Sayori, that's not funny at all.
Hmm, I grabbed Sayori by the shoulders I shake her really hard. What on earth are you saying?
Are you listening yourself right now
I know something happened to you
There's no other explanation for you to be like this
So tell me already until I know I won't be able to stop thinking about it
ahhhhh
Ha ha ha stop shaking me Sayori gives me an empty smile. You really put me in a trap, Morp.
But...
You're wrong
Nothing happened to me. I've always been like this. You're just seeing it for the first time seeing what?
What are you talking about Sayori?
You're really just gonna make me say it aren't you Morp I guess I have no choice this time the thing is
I've had really bad depression my whole life. Did you know that?
why do you think I'm late to school every day because
Most days I can't even find a reason to get out of bed
What reason is there to do anything when I fully know how worthless? I am why go to school?
Why eat? Why make friends why make other people put their energy and caring to waste by having them spend it on me
That's what it feels like and that's why I just want to make everyone happy
Without anyone worrying about me jeez I'm in shock
I can't even figure out how to respond how is it possible that Sayori kept this from me the entire time I've known her?
Did you really want so bad for me to just not think about her? Why Sayori?
Yeah
Why is it that you've never told me about this it almost feels like I've been betrayed
as your close friend because if I knew I would have done everything I could to support you
even if there's only so much that I could do I
Would have tried a little bit harder to make every day a little better for you
That's why I'm your friend. All you had to do was tell me
You don't understand it all Morp
Why do you think I didn't tell you?
Because if I told you then you would have to waste effort caring about me instead of doing important things
I don't want to be cared about it's bittersweet when people try to care about me. It feels nice sometimes
But it also feels like a bat being swung against my head
That's why I wanted so badly for you to make friends with everyone else
Helping everyone be happy together is the best thing for me, but then I discovered something else, too
Seeing you make friends and get closer with everyone in the club feels like a spear going through my heart
So that's why?
That's why I decided the world just wants to torture me every path leads to nothing but hurt
You're right that I don't understand I don't understand your feelings at all Sayori, but I don't need to understand
Whatever it is. Whatever it takes for me to help you stop hurting
That's what I'll do
No Morp, there's nothing
Nothing at all
The only thing that could have helped is if everything could be like it always was
But I was selfish I finally showed you what a horrible person I am
Tears streak down Sayori's face I
Made you join the literature club because I was selfish and I was punished by my heart hurting in a way that it couldn't understand
And now you came here, and I made you hurt, too. I'm just weak and selfish
That's all I am. Oh that's crazy thinking
That's why I'm going to accept these punishments
Because I deserve every last one. Oh, that's ridiculous
Without thinking I once again grab Sayori's shoulders
This time I pull her into a tight embrace
ahh
Morp Sayori I don't care if you feel selfish. I'm really happy that you convinced me to join the club
Seeing you every day makes it worthwhile enough if I make friends with everyone else, then that's just a bonus
but please never underestimate how much I care about you I
Wouldn't have it any other way
Morp...
Sayori isn't hugging me back despite my arms being wrapped around her, Saypri's arms remain at her sides
She starts sobbing next to my ear
No, don't do this to me. Please don't do this
Morp I
Sayori barely manages to speak between her sobs
I don't know if I'm doing the right thing but all I want is for her to know that I care
If you have it in you to call yourself selfish, then you have to let me be selfish too. No matter what it takes
I'll figure out what needs to change
I'll make these feelings go away
And if there's anything that you need me to do then. You'd better Tell me I'll get mad if you don't I
Don't know. I don't know I don't know
Gently, Sayori finally outs her arms around me in return. I don't know anything.
It's all really scary. I don't understand any of my feelings Morp.
The only time I'm not feeling nothing is when I'm feeling pained
But your hugs are so warm, and that's really scary to
Sayori let's me go as she does so I let her go as well
the festival's tomorrow
Yeah, it's gonna be fun, right
Yeah
How'd you like for me to spend it all with you?
um ah
It's what I want. I promise hey I
Think that would be nice then yeah
Savori wipes her eyes if I could spend the whole day here, I would
Of all days this has to be the one where I have other plans
Maybe I should cancel
No, don't please don't
If you did that then I really wouldn't forgive you
But it's almost time for Natsuki to meet me in my house at their very least do you want to come along and help out?
It would be fun to my surprise Sayori shakes her head. I'm sorry.
I don't know if that would be very good for me today you understand, right ah
It's kind of hard for me to fully understand it, but I'm trying my hardest
It's okay. Don't worry too much about it. I'll see you tomorrow. Okay. All right. I look forward to it
I would like if this was me I would have canceled plans right then and spend it all with Sayori, like
It doesn't even matter if like I'm in love or nothing. It's just like god
That's what a friend would do what friend should do just forget plans?
Natsuki would understand Sayori's the one that needs... on the way home
I find myself still feeling uneasy, but if it's hard for me to keep thinking about it when Natsuki is about to come over to
I think Sayori is right. I shouldn't be worrying too much, and we're definitely gonna have a great time tomorrow
I should just focus on what's ahead of me. Oh?
No, I don't know. I just feel bad about it
I spent only a few minutes back home
Anxiously awaiting Natsuki's arrival before I know she texts me to let me know she's outside the front door without delay
I opened the front door and let her in
Heyy!
Sup.
Hey, I don't know what I was expecting
But seeing Natsuki in something other than her school uniforms totally threw me off
Seeing her in such cute clothes make the uniform seem totally unfitting in comparison geez don't make it feel so awkward already
Stop staring at my clothes. It's gonna be a long afternoon
So don't just be weird just because you're not used to seeing me outside of school anyway. I'm coming in I
See you brought a lot of stuff Natsuki is carrying a large bag that it's probably full of baking supplies well
I didn't want to come all this way to find out that your kitchen isn't equipped for the job
So I'm moving in you brought everything I asked
Yeah, I did yesterday Natsuki asked me to buy a bunch of ingredients if I didn't already have them at home
Glad I could count on you to do your part. Well. I am mr.. Reliable
I'm surprised hear
Natuki suddenly say that rather than something snarky like she usually does
Could it be that. She's a little different outside school after all anyway. Let's go to the kitchen
Well you're not even gonna offer to take this heavy bag for me. Where's your hospitality Morp?
Come on
Since when did I need to be a gentleman? I grabbed the bag Natsuki holds out to me
Ghkk
Is ridiculously heavy?
I carried that all the way here. Are you impressed? I see now. I didn't know that you were so strong
Yeah, I'm impressed Natsuki seems like I always underestimate you and your strong body
Okay, it's because I'm so small isn't it you jerk. Natsuki hit's a fist into my chest
I go flying into the wall and break three of my ribs Hey size has nothing to do
Size has nothing to do with it. Natsuki. You really hate being small that much
um
It's not like I hate it. I mean sometimes. I like proving people wrong when they only think I'm worth my size
It's fun when I get to be small and also better than other people. Hey, I feel the same way
Natsuki, Morp read you loud and clear on that one, but jeez, never mind, what are you making me say?
Don't think it you can make me talk about weird things just because we're not at school
Are we getting started or what there's a lot of stuff I got to teach you
Haha, what that's a little bit more like you you're more fun when you just speak your mind like that
Hey, now you're treating me like a kid! Ugh.
I was just trying to be a little nicer, you know, and just because I don't have a mature and
Sexy figure like Yuri doesn't mean you should treat me like
that
Natsuki catches her words and her face turns red. Natsuki, how dare you mention Yuri's tall and sexy body?
Forget it. I didn't say anything I
should apologize
Yeah, I appreciate that you were trying to be nicer
I should have been a little bit more considerate, but also if that's what you're thinking
Then you should know that there are tons of guys who are into body types like yours
Now this conversation is suddenly taking a weird turn
How would you know that anyway
Just try trust me trust Morp on this one hmm. Anyway. Gross. Hey, what's that to me?
Who else?
Man, let's just get started already. Oh the sexual tension
It's getting too thick in here, ha ha, you get all sour when girls call you gross. I finally found your weakness Morp.
Natsuki smiles
Deviously, please spare me. Well, if Natsuki decided to dish out more insults like that
There's no way
I'm not fighting back, but she's satisfied enough for now finally starting to pull things out of her bag so we can get started
Okay
Before long the whole kitchen is a mess
spoons dirty bowls flour spilled fluid and plastic bags are strewn about every countertop. The mixer isn't big enough to make the batter at
Once so we had to do it several times meanwhile
Natsuki's babysitting all my movements to make sure I don't mess up for precious baking. Morp, where
Did you put the food coloring? The batter is going in the oven soon.
So I need to fill the trays. I think it's still in the bag next to the table
What are you using it for? To color the batter of course.
I'm making each tray a little different color that way even if the flavors aren't different everyone can still pick their favorite
That's a cute idea. You're cute. It's cute idea. Cutie. Are we doing anything like that with the eye thing do you want to ah?
You're asking me. I don't really have any preference so come on
You're not putting any heart into this can't you at least try to have fun? I'm having fun
baking
I'm not really sure. What Natsuki is trying to get out of me meanwhile
I see her separate the batter into smaller bowls and put a few drops of food coloring in each. It does look pretty cool
See it's not like baking is just about following instructions. The presentation is where you get to be creative.
I have the most fun. It's a million times more worth in the end if just looking at it makes everyones eyes light up.
Like the ones you made in the first day
I recall Natsuki proudly presenting her cat-shaped cupcakes, and Sayori and Monika's delighted expressions.
I wonder if I could make Natsuki proud like that too. Yeah. Maybe
I will use food coloring then. Sounds like you're starting to understand.
You starting to get it, eh? Just make sure you completely finish mixing the icing before you mess with the food coloring
Yeah, it's getting there
We were just using an electric mixer for the batter, so I got stuck with a whisk and a huge bowl
Don't worry Morp got mixing on lock got my speeds one and a million. It's all good
Yeah, the icing still all lumpy are you even trying? Well, yeah, it'll just take a little longer.
Jeez, I'll be here all night
If you do it like that here look. Grabs a whisk and uses her other hand to tilt the bowl back.
You need to really need to beat the ever-loving shit out of this
After a few seconds the consistency of the icing has already improved. See, ya dumb idiot! As if to emphasize,
Natsuki sticks a finger in the icing and pops in at her mouth. I reluctantly start to do the same
*Mark makes gross licking sounds*
Hey! Natsuki suddenly grabs my wrist
I don't want your gross fingers in my icing! Your icing aye? Are you forgetting who did all the work?
Start to fight back trying to inch my finger towards the bowl
Don't make me beat the crap out of you next I'd like to see you try ahaha
Slosh, just sprayer with a whole bowl of icing
I push harder just enough for my featured finger to reach the icing I
Triumphantly scoop some with my finger just as Natsuki tugs with all her might
Ahhgh!
The force of Natsuki's pulling caused me to stumble making her stumble in turn we fall on each other
Probably. Gross, you got it on my f--
*mark what are you thinking you immature child*
You got it on my face
Whose fault is that? There's a big glob of icing on Natsuki's cheek.
NNUUUuu
She tries to reach it with her tongue, but it's *laughs* too far away
Geez you know what take... THIS!
Natsuki instead wipes it off with her finger before shoving her finger towards my own face. You Wish! I'm
*immature mark laughs*
Faster I grabbed her wrist with my hand before it reaches my face. I don't like this conversation
I just don't like it. Natsuki tries to use her other hand to fight back, but I grab with that one as well
Wrassle wrassle
Hahaha stop. Haha not until you apologize for calling me gross
hahahaha
ehh
fine fine
hahaha
I'm sorry for calling you gross
You know I don't mean it it's just fun seeing you react to it
You do that to me all the time, ya know, saying dumb things just to get a reaction out of me
You really shouldn't tease girls like that. Is that soo? In that case, I probably shouldn't do this either.
I take Natsuki's finger and put it in my mouth, licking off the icing.
w-w-WHAT?
Did you seriously just-!
AHH!
Natsuki is so surprised that she can't even figure out how to get mad at me her face is entirely red
Morp, you really shouldn't do that kind of things to girls unless you...
unless you really like them. You know that, right?
Uhhh
What kind of question is she asking me, just like that?
It's just... the mood... the mood turned to this so quickly. SO QUICKLY
I've been uncomfortable for the past five minutes everybody in the comments is hiding behind their pillows GOD (it's true though)
alright, Oh Natsuki gazes at me in silence
I
Notice her shallow-I didn't think that word was breaths there for a second
Why am I starting to feel dizzy?
Ehh?
Hey, I don't know where the fire alarm starts going off Natsuki rushes over to the oven something burning
I thought you didn't put the cupcakes in yet?
No wonder you left a dirty tray in here, dummy. How could you make a mistake like that? You're finished!
She pulls out guns and shoots me right then and there
You should have checked before turning the oven on idiot. Don't blame me for your mistakes, dummy! Jeez.
Natsuki uses an oven mitt to
Grab the blackened tray out of the oven she sets it on top of the stove in another a moment the fire alarm stops
Annyway.... I'm
Putting them in the oven now
Yeah
the tension from the moment before still lingers over our heads
But the moment has already been lost
I watch as Natsuki slides the cupcake trays into the oven
Then I reluctantly pick up the whisk and continue with the icing like nothing ever happened
cuz nothing did ah
That smells so good
the cupcakes are already being
Ready to be pulled out of the oven as soon as natsuki opens the oven door a blast of sweet-smelling
Warm air fills the room. Look at how cute they all look. She proudly shows off each of the different colored cupcakes in each of the trays.
They'll look
Even better once we add the icing. Not like you need me to tell you that.
To tell me that... I brought decorating stuff, so I hope we can get creative
NOO
Don't do that. I've heard warnings about getting creative. Here, scoop the icing into these bags. Natsuki hands me some plastic bags
I have these....
Nozzles that will make it look nice and...
fluffy
This one can even make flowers. We probably won't be using it this time though, so I don't even know why I mentioned it
What's this one for? I pick up one of the nozzels that has a much thinner tip then the others. That ones really thin.
*overly dramatic eye-roll from Mark*
You know why that one is. You can also use it to write on a  cake, like happy birthday or whatever. Oh
I see okay that gives me an idea actually. An idea? Well,
It's a literature event right we can make it a little more literature themed by writing a different word on each of the cupcakes
It would be fun to see people choose their cupcake based on a word they like
uU
Hmm I was kind of expecting you to say something really stupid, and then you did that's actually a really cute idea so
Ahaha
Maybe I'm getting it from you,. What's that supposed to mean? I'm not cute!
*proof that Mark should never be allowed to blow a kiss in his life... ever*
Come on we're not at school nobody's judging you can't dress an act like this and not expect me to think you're cute
Well, Natsuki's voice trails off
same with you... cutie
Did you say something? No, nothing! Lets just
Do the icing Natsuki picks up the pace and fastens the nozzle onto each of the bags
There's a lot to do so we shouldn't be wasting time. Here I'll show you how to do it-and then ghosts
style, just right behind me just like the the the wheel of clay. Without giving me a chance to think about it,
Natsuki quickly moves on, she shows me how to apply the icing and then we each get to work
I wrote
Butthole on one just in case someone's favorite word is butthole you never know
aardvark for people who enjoy the beginning of the dictionary you know Oh
Markiplier for people that don't want a cupcake when we're finally finished Natsuki puts them all side by side to admire our work
Look at how pretty they are together look at how pretty we are together. Yeah, there
There are they I wish I could have one now well. There's no reason you can right
I don't see any harm in that. Oh, yeah, but my dad's making dinner tonight, so I really need to save my appetite
Uh-huh Sayori is exactly the opposite in that regard, if she was here,
She'd probably be down ten cupcakes already, and she would still eat dinner. C'mon,
That's just unhealthy besides when my dad cooks it need to eat as much of his as you can well anyway
I was hoping we would have time for
Manga, but I need to be home for dinner
Already that's a shame. It's your fault for working so slowly
You should have thought about that
It's not like you'll always have this chance.
What?
What are you talking about?
man... As
Usual Natsuki places the blame on me
You can bring the cupcakes tomorrow right if you and Sayori each carry something you probably do it in one trip
Yeah, I can do that. Don't worry. I won't let her eat any wink, ahaha
I wish you would listen to me the way she listens to you ah
Yeah, I think again back to the conversation I had with Sayori earlier today
I felt so helpless Sayori always does listen to me
But at that point it feels like she couldn't listen to me at all okay, I'm all packed up! Good work today!
I'll walk you out of gas
Soodly doot do do, just like that Natsuki is ready to leave. Feels like the afternoon went by in a flash.
More than that cuz I even take the opportunity to get closer to her like I wanted
Did I want that? Did I want that?
Well I guess I'll be off then
Thanks for all the help and everything. See you tomorrow
Wait Natsuki. Eh? What you said before about not always having this chance
doesn't have to be that way at all and
I fun today, you showed me how fun baking could be, like you wanted
Aside from that you can come over anytime
Okay, I think that if possible I'd like to spend more time like this if you want to read manga or go out somewhere oh
Ouhmm
Do you really mean that?
Natsuki looks at me tensely like she's trying to hide her expression. Yeah, I want to spend more time with you, baby
Morp...
I constantly forget how ridiculous Morp is. I thought you only cared about getting this done?
Whoa.... UUhh
I'm sorry. I had to leave so early today
I really didn't want to I would really stay here longer if I could. I feel the same way
As you so oh whoa hey whoa hey whoa hang on a second here
Hey, whoa, hey whoa? Hey? Whoa? Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait Natsuki
Standing inches from me Natsuki looks up at me
I feel her fingers gently clutch at the sides of my shirt as if holding onto me her
rose-colored cheeks and matching eyes fill my vision
Why does she have rose eyes by the way that's weird along with her slightly parted lips?
What is happening my head starts to go dizzy as I feel her soft breathszz against me
I felt itt
for a while now that
Sookie suddenly jumps back. Sayorii! Ahh
AHH
aa
Hi, Morp. Sayori! Just now, we weren't... Ehehee.
It's okay Morp. I just stopped by to say hi. Ahh
Well you should have come a little earlier I'm already on my way out so... Oh, really? That's too bad.
Yeah, well I'll still see you at the festival tomorrow, so its fine. Just don't eat any cupcakes before then, anyways, later
Clearly flustered Natsuki hurries off and Sayori waves goodbye
Sayori. I thought you didn't want to come over today.
Well, you know I have terrible timing so you know I decided to come over. I tried to stay in my room
But of my imagination was really being mean to me
So I had to come here and see it for myself. See what what are you talking about?
You know how much fun you were having with Natsuki and how close you got to her makes me...
really happy
That you've made such good friends is all that matters to me. Oh..
Geez tears started falling down. Seriously, that's all that matters to me. Why
I am I feeling this way Morp? I'm supposed to be happy for you
Why does it feel like my heart is splitting in half hurts so much
Everything hurts so much this would be so much better if I could just disappear. Oh come on Sayori, don't say that.
It's true Morp if I wasn't here, then you wouldn't have to waste your sympathy on me
You wouldn't have to put up with me being selfish. Monika was right, I should just.......... what?
Monika Monika was right about what?Eh? Sayori, what I said before is true
I'm not gonna let this continue
Caring about you like this isn't the burden your mind is making it out to be it's something that makes me happy
It's something that I wouldn't trade for anything else so even if it takes an entire lifetime
I'm gonna be by your side until you don't feel any more pain. What's that's quite.... That's quite a statement to make!
but
Sayori looks away, I put a hand on her shoulder to reassure her. I'm scared Morp. Really scared. What are you scared of, Sayori?
I'm scared that that I might like you more than you like me
Sayori.. It's true. Isn't it I was weak and started to like you too much. I did this to myself
Morp, I like you so much that I want to die. Oh, that's how I feel and
That's enough Sayori. I don't want you to hurt anymore
I slide my hand down Sayori's arm and squeeze her hand in my own. Do you remember?
How I said I always know what's best for you
Do you still believe me in that rather egotistical statement that I just said?
Wordlessly Sayori nods even if you don't understand all of your own feelings. I know that you need the most right now
I know what you need the most and that's what I'm gonna give you
What am I gonna give you?
ugh burhuah
You'll always be my dearest friend
Sayori. Well. I like you better than Natsuki. I like you better than Yuri.
I love ya? I love ya. Love ya. You'll alwa... love you. I love you Sayori. What would happen!
Probably something terrible, alright, imma go with I love you.
That seems like right cuz I really thought like Natsuki all that much. I love you.
I love you
Yeah, those are my true feelings
So there's no way you could make me like you like me more than I like you
I should have realized it sooner
But spending time with everyone at the club
Making new friends and having fun with you every day it helped me realize that you are truly the most important person to me
That's why I'll accept any of your burdens as long as we can continue this everyday
With you by my side, then I know we'll both be happy... Morp...
*smol very cute noise*
Suddenly, Sayori wraps her arms tightly around me. Morp... is this really okay?
Yeah
I hold Sayori in my arms and pull her closer. You'll never have to let go of me again, I
Love you Morp. I want to be with you forever
Me too
But we're both in high school, so you know?
College... and whatever
Anyway, I feel Sayori's grip around me weaken a little bit. What is this?
Sayori... I'm supposed to be happy right now. I always thought this would be the happiest moment for me. But why... Even now
Why won't the rain clouds go away?
They're not going away at all Morp. It's ok Sayori, it might take some time for things to get better again
But no matter how long it takes I'll be there every step of the way. That's all that matters right now
Ok I trust you
Sayori and I slowly release each other. So I guess that makes the festival tomorrow our first date, huh?
Hey, what are you saying? I don't want to think about those things
You know I want everything to be the same as it always has been
Even if we really are a couple. I don't know if I could handle anything more right now
it's really nuew and scary to me I
Understand we'll go at whatever pace suits you best. Hey, Morp?
Sayori gazes at me once again, smiling sadly. Even if I get  really really sad, this is the best thing for me, right?
Eh, I don't really understand what Sayori means by that. Are you saying that this is making you feel sad Sayori?
I don't know. I don't understand what I'm feeling feels like a bunch of thorns when you told me you loved me
That's why I want to trust you.
You know what's best for me yeah. I do that's my promise. I say that but in reality
I've never felt more uncertain when it comes to Sayori...
I know that I love her and she loves me
But I'm having as much trouble understanding Sayori's feelings as she is even though I can comfort her,
I keep wondering if I should be doing something more something different..
I know these thoughts will continue to plague me until things are back to the way they were
Is that what Sayori meant by not wanting anything to change?
Don't know, but I know that I'll give it everything I've got, Sayori is the most important person to me.
I'll do whatever it takes to have a happy future with her.
Oh
It's a day of the festival well alright
Then I'm gonna end this episode here cuz I gotta wrap my head around everything that just happened
So thank you everybody so much for watching. I don't know what's going on
I don't know what's going on, but it's obvious right now that Monika is pulling some strings behind the scenes
That much is very readily evident
And I don't know why to what end but I think we're gonna find out in the next one
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye <3